welcome back all right nate promised a
sexy show and we've got one and i know
we've seen sexy on the strip before but
rouge is the sexiest show in vegas and
it's an immersive interactive sensual
experience it's the strat and i'm so
excited to have on the show here zion
joining us this morning and nicolette
hello you guys are dressed up and you
look beautiful you're ready for the
performance tonight well thank you very
much i mean
glitz and glamour
yes and fully clothed here at this hour
which we you know appreciate no problem
at all it's true the rumor is true it is
a topless show i myself am topless i
know that's what y'all talking about
that's what you want to see you've got
to come to the show to see that i'm not
gonna do that right now in the morning
pay for that yeah okay
so now of course tickets are gonna start
about 49 and it is for 18 and up so this
is an adult show but it's not just a
sexy show there is a lot of talent on
stage what are people gonna see
oh they're gonna see everything you know
me myself i do a lot of acrobats i know
looking at me you can assume that with
my amazing physique right here
we're all acrobats we do very high level
acrobatics in this show i mean yeah for
one part she's staying on my head on a
point show
and we were just seeing some of the
video too kind of like what people can
expect and there's dancing as well yeah
we've got dancers acrobats obviously
amazing comedy from these guys
true actually
[Laughter]
humble brown
i try to stay humble but it's hard you
know but ladies and gentlemen we got
everything you could want we got all
kinds of acrobatics we got six
generations circus family we got
everything and this is
about a month into it yeah okay about
five weeks now yeah we've been running
about five weeks and it going splendidly
this morning good and two shows a night
is that uh two show on a tuesday two
show on a sunday like a sandwiches show
we got one show all in the middle
yeah you guys are busy
and welcome by the way to las vegas we
love having our performers here you're
new to america i'm new to america yes i
am i'm not from these possible you know
i'm getting used to everything i was
gonna say it sounds like you just came
right from texas and nicolette you did a
show here before now you're back after
yeah
for a couple of years yeah excited to be
back in vegas oh well we are so glad to
have you guys is there anything that
parents or i shouldn't say parents
because parents are going to be going to
this but folks need to know when they're
coming to the show and we're watching
some of this video this is really just
spectacular the costuming is amazing
yeah it's amazing the costumes like our
costume designers from israel and she
honestly there the detail on them it's
amazing it is and you know
the parents can come along they just got
to leave their kids with a babysitter
family member y'all come on this show is
for everybody nobody's going to feel
alienated here we got women we got men
we got everything you could want
everything in between a nice flavor okay
so you've got the comedy and the
performance i love it at the strat
good excellent so you guys are going to
take a nap and you're going to be on the
the stage tonight 8 o'clock yeah
absolutely
now maybe i've taken that maybe i don't
we see where we go
this
is thank you congratulations we love it
go see this new wonderful show at the
strat
rouge
thank you thank you so much
thank you very much